[Música]
revista de prensa en directo a de
francés 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa pared más de euros o bienvenida
buena mañana de viernes ya finalizamos
una semana más del programa abrimos
entonces nuestra sección con las
portadas de periódicos argentinos esto
tras la designación de sergio massa como
el súper ministro de economía un cargo
que agrupa la responsabilidad del
ministerio de producción agricultura y
el de economía por supuesto la pregunta
entonces es como lo titula el clarín
buenos días exactamente recordemos a
sergio massa presidente de la cámara de
diputados y líder también del frente
renovador una fuerza integrada dentro
del frente de todos bien clarín
básicamente como el resto de periódicos
que hemos querido seleccionar pues
señalan que el reto es enorme el de
sacar a argentina de la delicada
situación económica que atraviesa desde
hace años en todo caso clarín titula
intentan frenar la crisis económica
dándole poder a massa y señala la
reestructuración desde gabinete de
alberto fernández señalan scioli vuelve
a brasil el que era ministro de
producción durante los últimos 44 días y
mandan a silvia na batakis la ministra
de economía desde el 3 de julio que ha
tirado pues eso unos 25 días al banco
nación señala a clarín que es una señal
de cuestión para los mercados y
sentencia el gobierno juega su última
carta la nación rosa la nación titula
giro político masa toma todo el control
del área económica y asegura que ha sido
pues una cesión de fernández a las
presiones internas con esta jugada dice
que básicamente este movimiento desnuda
la debilidad del presidente alberto
fernández y citó unas líneas más a llega
con un poder inédito no reportará al
jefe del gabinete sino directamente a
alberto fernández y a cristina kirchner
por otro lado aseguran a que massa según
una cuenta la gente de su alrededor
respetará el pacto con el fondo
monetario internacional- quiere traer
dólares al país sobre todo basándose en
la explotación del litio y recuerdan
también que más con el kirchnerismo en
2013 y mencionan una cita suya de 2015
diciendo yo no quiero que el
kirchnerismo siga y no tengo problema en
decirlo dicen así con la nueva
designación completa un recorrido que
comenzó en 2019 al firmar las paces con
cristina kirchner e integrar el frente
de todos reconocí nador se rosa
página/12 por el contrario asegura que
ésta no ha sido una debilidad de alberto
fernández sino un intento decir una
decisión consensuada entre todas las
patas del oficialismo y recalcan el
apoyo de la cgt el histórico
importantísimo sindicato de trabajadores
de argentina a este cambio y ayer rosa
ya cambiando de tema como también lo
dijimos en nuestro noticiero en su
programa fue el día el llamado día de
sobregiro de la tierra que alerta una
vez más de la insostenibilidad del modo
de vida que estamos llevando en este
momento como parte pues de la sociedad
digamos mundial en la que pertenecemos
por lo que hoy queríamos hacer
referencia a un tema que también ha
estado resonando toda esta semana y es
los viajes en jet privado de los
multimillonarios también una polémica
con una de las kardashian keily jenny y
por eso como que también se está todo
absolutamente todo esto y evidenció aún
más esta problemática exactamente y un
modo de vida que digamos no carga con la
misma responsabilidad en función de la
clase social de cada persona y también
de su de su lugar de origen y de donde
habitan bien en referencia como bien
decías a los jets privados no the
gardian a publicó una lista que tituló
criminales climáticos a tiempo completo
y en esta lista clasificaba los viajes
realizados en un jet privado más cortos
entre junio y julio de este año una
lista encabezada por el ex boxeador
floyd mayweather seguido de kylie jenner
como bien decía si está miembro de las
kardashian que no sabría cómo tampoco
definir como una figura pop si una
figura pública influencers digan exacto
y que tendrían en tercer lugar al rapero
drake en todo caso centrándonos en el de
kylie jenner que como bien decía se ha
desatado mucha polémica en redes
sociales se trata de un viaje de 17
minutos dentro del estado de california
que emitió una tonelada de co2 lo que
significa una cuarta parte de lo que
emite una persona con sus actividades de
media en un año en todo caso también nos
da otras informaciones este medio the
gardian y es que un viaje en jet privado
por la media por personas suelen ser
unas 14 veces más contaminante que un
avión comercial y unas 50 veces más
contaminantes que el mismo trayecto en
tren en todo caso está monitoreo de los
trayectos entre privados los siguen
distintas cuentas de twitter que ustedes
pueden consultar como celebrity jets
también hay al que sigue particularmente
el set de y lo más que recordemos el en
jet jeff bezos jets o el avión de
bernard en referencia a bernard arnault
el propietario francés de él ve además
rosa y cerramos esta revista de prensa
con una sátira gráfica sobre la
actualidad energética en este momento
sobre todo en europa
exactamente dos viñetas que ilustran muy
bien las consecuencias para la unión
europea de estas las sanciones impuestas
al rusia y digamos a su reacción que
afecta directamente a la dependencia
energética de bruselas al respecto a
moscú vemos este dibujo de coco en
liberación al que no hace falta añadirle
muchas palabras no muy oportuno con toda
la polémica en relación a la suministro
de la noche de gas a través del 232 y
por otro lado vemos en mediapart este
esta viñeta de al anbar en su blog
particular vemos a emanuel macro na
recibiendo a la príncipe heredero de
arabia saudita bin salman no al que la
inteligencia estadounidense considera el
autor intelectual del asesinato del
periodista llama al caso vino y en la
que fue su primera visita francia desde
ese asesinato y recordemos que macrón a
precisamente justificado esta recepción
diciendo que hay que diversificar las
fuentes energéticas de la unión europea
frente a esta posible corte total del
garros gracias.rosa como siempre por
esta revista de prensa ya finalizamos
una semana feliz fin de semana hacha
para usted los demás el lunes con más y
pasamos
no es la primera en vitalia